hello you guys uh so today we're going
to do a
2017 OK last
Impreza
2017 uh we went in Subaru Subaru and we
went on
uh I'm going to show you
guys so I went to Subaru I went by
model I clicked smart
key and then I went
into control unit keyless
system and as you can see the car is in
panic no key
detected I'm going to go remote control
learning and we're going to do
uh call connecting to Subaru starlink
Emergency Services
so the AO of the current vehicle we
didn't save it so we're going to read it
from the vehicle right
now so now it's basically reading the
data so then we're going to be able to
uh start the car uh using
this um in a very easy
way uh and also to add a key so we can
present the car with this key
[Music]
after a Reddit we just going to save it
call connecting to Subaru starlink
emergency services and we're going to
press
okay um so we connected this so we're
just going to press
okay call connect so the generated key
is completed now we just going to take
it and put it on the push to start and
we're going to try pressing with
that and as you can see car is
on
uh so now we're going to be able to uh
add a key or or do whatever we need um
since the car is out of panic so we're
just going to generate the key and we're
going to show you guys how we adding
it okay so we're generating the key um I
going to show you guys which one I
chose um so the generate analog key is
successfully so we're just going to
press okay and now we can promo uh
perform the add a key
function so we're going to press that
this one is the the key generation uh
will be
done okay so it's finished generating I
used the this
one and let's see if it does the job so
we're just going to press add a
key um we're just going to press
okay so we're going to put the
close we heard the one beep so now we're
going to take another the new key and
you're just going to place it on the
push to start and here it says okay that
it has three so we're just going to
press
okay call connec to Subaru starlink
Emergency
Services turn the ignition
off open and close the
door and turn the ignition on with the
key so we use the key on the push to
start the learning is successful so we
use the generat
key and as you can see the remote is
[Music]
working this is how you do a 2017
Impreza all key lost uh just like that
with the outo generated uh emulator and
using the universal Keys uh there is one
more small fix that you can do uh the
trunk off the
B uh doesn't look like it's working so
to Subaru
St that we're just going to go here on
the
comments and as you can see that
uh people that from the United States um
they've been saying that they use the
the the Zer C uh for the trunk
button um so we can try uh doing that so
we're just going to put the key here and
we going to press modify button distance
we're going to hit the read
button and then we're going to go here
instead of 0 a which is going to do uh 0
C and press okay and press the settings
which means
right right successfully
now as you can see the trunk is working
so this is how you even can fix uh the
trunk button so everything is working
perfectly thank you guys for watching